the biggest advantage that a salesman
has is that the person has already said
they have a problem you said you needed
help I'm here how can I help you a lot
of sales is clear communication it's
being clear about why we're here and
then we get agreement that we understood
the problem that they said they had next
and then from that point we have to turn
the desire into a decision whenever we
rework a sales script with any of the
portfolio companies a lot of times they
have all this Gobbledy cook and so I
like the shortest possible scripts
because a lot of communication is wasted
they say hello build rapport talk for 30
minutes see that there's time that's
running out and then realize they have
to pitch right and so then they motor
mouth and then just awkwardly ask it's
not normal human communication and
you're not providing value to the other
person